So you want to be an astronaut?
Well I hope you have good health insurance!
Hi there spacewalking hopefuls!
I’m Ian for DNews: Now….Space is a horrible,
horrible place.
As soon as humans exit the lovely, snug atmosphere
of Earth, the cosmos is out to kill us.
I’m not kidding; there’s radiation from
the sun, cosmic rays from distant supernovas
and even chunks of space debris traveling
faster than a speeding bullet!
These killers are a very real threat to astronauts
in space, but they’re only the tip of the
iceberg.
After spending a record-breaking one year
in space, NASA astronaut Scott Kelly reported
some rather uncomfortable issues with his
prolonged exposure to the microgravity environment
onboard the International Space Station.
Interestingly, when he landed on Earth in
March, Kelly was one and a half inches taller
than when he was when he launched into orbit.
The lack of Earth’s gravity caused his spine
to expand, which quickly got squashed again
after landing.
And this underscores an astronaut’s biggest
problem in space: Gravity.
Or the lack of it.
Kelly complained of muscle pain; his eyesight
was temporarily altered and his skin became
ultra-sensitive after he landed.
Immediately after reaching Earth, his blood
pressure dropped -- his heart wasn’t used
to pumping in a gravitational environment,
so dizziness and temporary loss of balance
were obvious concerns.
There’s always a period of adjustment to
Earth gravity after being in space, but Kelly’s
mission was longer than most and some of his
health issues persisted.
Kelly’s one-year stint on the space station
wasn’t designed to torture the veteran astronaut,
however.
It was an experiment to see how the human
body changes in space.
And Kelly was a special case; he had a twin
brother, Mark, on Earth to act as his terrestrial
control.
During his orbital stay, Kelly participated
in a range of tests and had to engage in vigorous
exercise for 2 hours a day that all astronauts
and cosmonauts have to endure to stave off
the effects of muscle atrophy.
Bone wastage, that is common in osteoporosis
patients on Earth, is also an issue for astronauts.
To combat it, many take the drug bisphosphonate
to counter the effects of bone loss.
They also take supplements like calcium and
vitamin D, but the most effective counter
to bone and muscle loss is lots and lots of
exercise.
The future of space exploration will likely
spawn a whole new sector in the pharmaceutical
market.
If astronauts have problems sleeping (which
is a common complaint while strapped to your
bed while speeding above Earth at over 17
THOUSAND miles per hour), they can drop a
sleeping pill.
Feeling tired?
Drop a Modafinil which, according to a 2009
Canadian Medical Association Journal report,
“is available to crew to optimize performance
while fatigued.”
Say if a crewmate starts acting erratic and
becomes a danger to the rest of the crew?
Well, that’s why there are tranquilizers
on board…. and duct tape.
I’m not kidding.
So, medically-speaking, we’re still trying
to figure this space thing out.
Our bodies are used to a gravitational environment
with a 24-hour circadian cycle, not a microgravity
environment with a 90-minute orbital cycle,
so there’s bound to be some problems.
But all these problems have surfaced while
we live only a couple of hundred miles above
Earth -- how the heck are we going to deal
with the health issues facing us when we finally
send astronauts to Mars?
During that long trip to Mars, our intrepid
explorers will be bathed in radiation from
high-energy particles from the sun and deep
space in the form of cosmic rays.
When going to Mars, we’ll need spaceships
equipped with some novel radiation shielding,
but even then they’ll likely encounter a
variety of unaccounted-for space radiation-related
cancers.
So, would I still want to be an astronaut?
Actually, yes.
Humanity is really good at pushing the envelope
and discovering new things about our universe.
The next big step is to see humanity on Mars
and though it’s going to be a challenge,
I think we’ll persevere, develop some really
strong space drugs and eventually become a
true space-faring civilization.
To maintain muscle mass and strength, astronauts
have some pretty cool machines to work out
with, check out Lizette’s space fitness
video to find
out more!
Knowing that a mission to Mars could kill
you, would you still want to go?
Tell us in the comments section down below
and don’t forget click subscribe for new
episodes every day.
I’ll see you next time on DNews.